darting infield now he's got support
here oh and get back in the game
[Applause]
FIFA has struggled on the pitch in its
past few iterations with matches
deteriorating too frustrating slugs for
years we've been unable to play fee for
like footballs played in real life
instead we've been zigzagging the ball
up the pitch and abusing Pacey wingers
to breach the opponent's defense and
swinging an unstoppable cross for an
equally unstoppable header FIFA
nineteen's matches a more natural or
more varied in the way they unfold well
though ea introduced a slower pace and
fee for 18 the newest iteration finally
makes this work by tightening up players
responsiveness
through passes and player pace are in a
good place in terms of balance neither
under nor overpowered as has been the
case for too long
FIFA 19's ball still doesn't feel as
satisfying as PES 2019 s but it does at
least feel something like the real-life
sphere it's attempting to imitate FIFA
19 includes new tactical options for
wannabe managers to fiddle with these
are undoubtedly welcome and changes in
your defensive technique make a tangible
impact in-game allowing you to further
tailor your play style however the much
vaunted new feature of game plans or a
bit of a mess any change to one game
plan including your default starting
plan is not automatically reflected in
your other four plans this isn't a deal
breaker of course but it inevitably ends
with you spending more time in the team
management menu which is exactly the
kind of admin work this feature should
have eradicated and despite the added
depth of options the vast majority of AI
teams still behave in a broadly similar
and often unrealistic way FIFA's brand
of footballs become much more physical
this year with strength becoming a far
more important stat and crunching
collisions feeling much more realistic
you can see and feel players battling
for the ball and goalkeepers are not
quite as invincible from crosses as in
previous years long ball tactics are
slightly more viable as a result
including mercifully from free kicks
despite this and the new tactical
options there's still no way to
determine which players go up four
corners of free kicks taking inspiration
from gears of wars active reload time
finishing attempts to add more depth to
FIFA's pitch work for expert players and
while it can be a little temperamental
and fiddly it does add a nice risk
reward layer to what was previously a
function that become an afterthought
after 20 years of muscle memory
[Applause]
meanwhile A's implementation of the
newly acquired Champions League and
Europa League licences is excellent with
the official branding specific
commentators and authentic atmospheres
adding to the feel of this being club
football's biggest event the competition
has its own mode in FIFA 19 as well as
implementation in the journey ultimate
team and career mode and to its credit
EA utilizes the license in a much more
comprehensive way than Konami ever did
unfortunately that's pretty much it in
terms of new career mode features and
this is where FIFA 19 suffers career
mode is the most in-depth single-player
mode remaining in FIFA and yet it is
seen almost no meaningful improvements
for years this year the mode has not
been touched at all save for the
implementation of the Champions League
and the cracks are showing
similarly pro clubs is exactly the same
this year as it was in fee for 18 and
it's hard not to sympathize with those
who speculate around EA is shifting
priorities given how much attention the
microtransaction driven ultimate team
receives in comparison frankly to modes
as big and as popular as these receiving
no new features or even any quality of
life improvements is unacceptable and EA
needs to up its game here next year
kickoff is where most of EA's offline
attention was focused this time around
the introduction of detailed stats and
some interesting new sub modes contained
within House Rules
these allow you to turn off fouls and
off sites or turn on the battle rail
like survival mode in which a goal
results in one of your players being
sent off or disallow any goal not score
from header or volley these modes are
shallow and being available in local
play only is a baffling decision but
they do offer a nice change of pace for
when you're playing with a friend
ultimate seems major new feature this
year is a new sub mode named division
rivals a replacement for the now cut
online seasons mode it's another shorter
way to qualify for the fuc champions
weekend of it and adds to the
ever-growing and evolving behemoth
Ultimate Team has become otherwise
Ultimate Team remains largely the same
but the most strength lies more on its
constant live support over the course of
a season champions cards limited-time
packs daily and weekly objectives
special events in tournaments Ultimate
Team has something to draw you in every
week and it's truly the lifeblood of
FIFA 19 the journeys 3rd year sees the
conclusion of Alex hunter story but
sister Kim and best mate Danny Williams
join him as playable characters in a GTA
5 esque three-pronged story each
character has their own special features
such as Alex's choice of mentor squad at
Real Madrid or Danny's choice of advert
he wants to take part in the journey
scripting and acting isn't exactly
outstanding but it remains a unique way
to play it's promising the EA is
listening to its community FIFA 19 is
much more responsive on the pitch than
last year and it continues to evolve
Phut to keep it fresh however it must
once again listen to its fans and
realize the lack of progress in career
mode and pro clubs is appalling
thankfully the journeys continued
entertainment firts long lasting
addictive nature and some inventive new
kickoff modes mean I'll likely still be
playing Fifa 19 by the time next year's
game rolls around is confident on the
Bali showed it
[Applause]